bueno este es momento de actualizar la
información en materia económica en
france 24 y para eso nos acompaña por
supuesto nuestro compañero jorge hurtado
jorge muy buenas noches bueno comenzamos
con una de las noticias del día finalizó
la reunión de los líderes de eeuu canadá
y méxico contános de que se habló en
materia económica así es bueno en
materia económica el principal tema se
centró en los incentivos fiscales a los
vehículos eléctricos propuestos por eeuu
en el proyecto de ley de servicios
sociales que está causando preocupación
en canadá los automóviles y camiones son
los productos manufacturados más
comercializados entre los tres países
canadá y méxico buscan igualdad de
condiciones mientras que estados unidos
su mayor socio comercial
también tiene disposiciones en el plan
de gastos de eeuu que va a ofrecer a los
consumidores un crédito fiscal de siete
mil quinientos dólares si compran
vehículos eléctricos hasta el año 2026
al año siguiente sólo las compras de
vehículos eléctricos hechos en estados
unidos tendrían este beneficio este
asunto es vital para los intercambios
entre los tres países que comercializan
14 billones de dólares al año
uno de los países que protagonizó este
encuentro precisamente fue en méxico un
país donde hay alarma ahora por los
niveles de inflación así es y sobre todo
después de las declaraciones del
subgobernador del banco de méxico quien
calificó la alza sostenida de los
precios como una situación bastante
grave
jonathan heath su gobernador del banxico
dijo hoy que la inflación general de
méxico podría superar el 7 por ciento en
la tasa anual de noviembre el
funcionario agregó que la inflación
podría cerrar este año entre 7.1 o 7.3
por ciento tomando datos del instituto
nacional de estadística geografía de
cumplirse esta estimación este sería el
dato más alto para 20 años el banco de
méxico- basa el problema de la inflación
en choques de oferta y demanda y a
cambios en los patrones que han sido
según sus palabras difíciles de entender
hasta octubre la inflación se mantiene
en seis puntos 24 por ciento su mayor
nivel desde 2017 y es el doble del
objetivo del 3% que se habían propuesto
las autoridades el banco de méxico
también subió hoy el tipo de interés en
25 puntos básicos por cuarta vez
consecutiva hasta el 5% mientras los
mercados esperaban más subidas esto
plantea santiago mayores riesgos para el
proceso de formación de precios y las
expectativas de la inflación según las
autoridades hablemos ahora de la
compañía apple que está innovando y
quiere invertir en la construcción de
vehículos eléctricos así así se espera
que presente su primer vehículo autónomo
para el año 2025 el carro eléctrico de
apple no tendría ni timón ni pedales y
estaría diseñado con interiores para la
conducción sin manos tras la publicación
las acciones de apple aumentaron un 3
por ciento en la bolsa el proyecto
automotriz bea paul inició en 2014
cuando comenzaron a desarrollar un
vehículo desde cero y se conoce como
proyecto titán una nueva conciencia
ambiental ha aumentado la demanda de
vehículos eléctricos generando ganancias
para empresas del sector como tesla
irradian que ya valen más que
fabricantes tradicionales como ford por
ejemplo según la fuente las
posibilidades de que en 2025 presente su
propio vehículo eléctrico son superiores
al 50 por ciento aunque hablemos un poco
más de esto los eléctricos porque el
nuevo modelo que fueron presentados en
los ángeles verdad se trata del evento
salón del automóvil de los ángeles donde
los competidores de tesla mostraron
nuevos vehículos y hasta a mejor precio
por ejemplo aquí al ardió en el evento
sobre un nuevo modelo que según ellos
supera a tesla en el tiempo de carga que
es más corto y que ronda las 5 horas
esta información es de yahoo finance kia
y hyundai llegaron al evento con
vehículos deportivos de gran tamaño con
tres filas de asientos la apuesta por
los super eléctricos es un reflejo de la
preferencia de los americanos por este
tipo de vehículos sólo este año se
comprarán unos 5,6 millones de vehículos
eléctricos según bloomberg asimismo se
instalaron unos 2,1 millones de
cargadores de vehículos en todo el mundo
un 65 por ciento más que el año pasado
vamos ahora con los indicadores de la
jornada que nos dicen wall street cerró
mixto pero el estándar en por 500 y el
nasdaq volvieron a récords en europa la
bolsa cerraron a la baja arrastradas por
la debilidad de los valores relacionados
con las materias primas en medio de la
caída de los precios del petróleo y los
metales y en américa latina la bolsa
argentina cerró con
tres días después de las sacudidas que
ha tenido por las elecciones
absolutamente bueno para finalizar como
siempre la tan esperada cifra del día
cuál es esta vez 200 millones de dólares
ese es el monto que negoció borrar music
para comprar el catálogo musical de tape
y powe gracias jorge por otra
completísima crónica hasta aquí la
información económica en france 24 los
invitamos a continuar informando se en
el resto de nuestra programación y en
france 24 punto com
[Música]